- [Instructor] "The
differentiable function f
"and its derivative f prime are graphed."
So, let's see.
We see the graph of y is equal
to f of x here in the blue.
And then f prime we see in
this brownish-orangish color
right over here.
"What is an appropriate
calculus-based justification
"for the fact that f is decreasing
"when x is greater than three?"
So, we can see that that
actually is indeed the case.
When x is greater than three,
we see that our function
is indeed decreasing.
As x increases, the y value,
the value of our function, decreases.
So, a calculus-based justification,
without even looking at the choices,
well, I could look at the derivative.
And we're going to be decreasing
if the slope of the
tangent line is negative,
which means that the
derivative is negative.
And we can see that for
x is greater than three,
the derivative is less than zero.
So, my justification,
I haven't even looked
at these choices yet.
I would say for x is greater than three,
f prime of x is less than a zero.
That would be my justification,
not even looking at these choices.
Now let's look at the choices.
"f prime is decreasing when
x is greater than three."
Now, this isn't right.
What we care about is
whether f prime is positive or negative.
If f prime is negative,
if it's less than zero,
than the function itself is decreasing.
The slope of the tangent
line will be negative.
f prime could be positive
while decreasing.
For example, f prime could
be doing something like this.
And even though f prime
would be decreasing
in this situation, the actual value
of the derivative would be positive,
which means the function
would be increasing
in that scenario, so I
would rule this one out.
"For values of x larger than
three, as x values increase,
"the values of f of x decrease."
Now, that is actually true.
This is actually the definition
that f is decreasing.
As x values increase, the
values of f of x decrease.
But this is not a
calculus-based justification,
so I am going to rule
this one out as well.
"f prime is negative when
x is greater than three."
Well, that's exactly what I wrote up here.
If f prime is negative, then that means
that our slope of the tangent line
of our original function f is
going to be downward sloping,
or that our function is decreasing,
so this one is looking good.
And this one right over here says,
"f prime of zero is
equal to negative three,"
so they're just pointing out this point.
This isn't relative to the
interval that we care about,
or this isn't even relevant
when x is greater than three,
so we definitely wanna rule that one out.
Let's do one more of these.
So, here we're told, "The
differentiable function g
"and its derivative g prime are graphed."
So, once again, g is in this bluish color,
and then g prime, its derivative,
is in this orange color.
"What is an appropriate
calculus-based justification
"for the fact that g has
a relative minimum point
"at x is equal to negative three?"
And we could see here, when
x is equal to negative three,
it looks like g is equal to negative six,
and it looks like a relative
minimum point there.
So, what's the best justification?
So, once again, without
even looking at the choices,
I would say a good justification is
before we get to x equals negative three,
our derivative, and this is a
calculus-based justification,
before we go to x equals negative three,
our derivative is negative.
And after x equals negative three,
our derivative is positive.
That would be my justification.
Because if our derivative is
negative before that value,
that means that we are downward
sloping before that value.
And if it's positive after that value,
that means we're upward
sloping after that,
which is a good justification
that we are at relative
minimum point right over there.
So, let's see, "The point
where x equals negative three
"is the lowest point on the graph of g
"in its surrounding interval."
That is true,
but that's not a
calculus-based justification.
You wouldn't even have
to look at the derivative
to make that statement, so
let's rule that one out.
"g prime has a relative
maximum at zero comma three."
At zero comma three, it actually does not.
Oh, g prime, yes,
g prime actually does
have a relative maximum
at zero comma three, but
that doesn't tell us anything
about whether we're at
a relative minimum point
at x equals negative three,
so I would rule that out.
"g prime of negative
three is equal to zero."
So, g prime of negative
three is equal to zero,
so that tells us that the
slope of the tangent line
of our function is going to
be zero right over there,
but that by itself is not enough
to say that we are at
relative minimum point.
For example, I could be at
a point that does something
like this where the slope
of the tangent line is zero,
and then it keeps increasing again,
or it does something like
this and it keeps decreasing.
So, even though you're at a point
where the slope of your
tangent line is zero,
it doesn't mean you're at
a relative minimum point,
so I would rule that out.
"g prime crosses the x-axis
from below it to above it
"at x equals negative three."
g prime crosses the x-axis
from below it to above it.
Yep, and that's the argument that I made,
that we're going from below the x-axis,
so g prime goes from being
negative to positive,
which means the slope of the tangent lines
of our points as we approach
x equals negative three go
from being downward
sloping to upward sloping,
which is an indication
that we are at a relative minimum point.